now all we're missing is the fire sort
of oh you mean this yeah could you get
this by side in damien darhk's pocket i
thought you know that would make a sick
souvenir cool
souvenir if that's how you feel why keep
it at all
souvenir peach hey everybody its charlie
oh my Grod we finally have wally west on
the Waverider they pretty much threw
everything they had at this episode we
had a bunch of flash stuff that was a
bunch of Indiana Jones I feel like a lot
of the energy from the episode came from
the fact that Brandon Ralph and his wife
in real life were acting together in the
episodes and it seems like they're kind
of pushing them together too
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos it's gonna be like this for the
rest of the season like didn't I say it
was gonna be that much better when Wally
West came on but there's a new round of
that blast ring giveaway in obviously
careful for spoilers from the episode
but let's do top 10 WTF and comic book
Easter eggs the new Legion of Doom
learns that they have to reform the fire
totem and then they turned it into this
big running gag for the end of the
episode oh we believe little petty theft
is okay here we call them souvenirs and
then you get that young justice easter
egg just taking a little souvenir from
our adventure here which is most of you
guess is why I put that clip at the
beginning
speaking of which Young Justice season 3
coming later this year you'll want to
see this
but number nine you have all those
shifting alliances so you have kuwasa
versus the legion of doom like kuwasa
versus nor dark because Nora's wearing
her family's spirit totem they also have
the fire totem which was used to kill
her during the vixen animated series I
put the clip of that in the trailer
video that I posted this morning so if
you didn't see it that you could just go
back and watch that trailer video but
the number 8 a Maya's grandmother also
tells Amaya that she needs to get kou
haces help to save the day like
basically they're gonna need to win her
over
rey is trying to save the soul of nora
dark so you kind of see what everyone's
Ark is gonna be this season it's a
little bit clearer than it's been in
previous seasons but number 7 we get the
Mallis explainer turns out he's this
time demon that the original totem bear
is trapped out of time space the more
the time fractures the easier it is for
him to break free of his prison into our
reality which is a very dark knights
metal thing if you haven't been reading
dark knights metal it was a big comic
book arc number 6 a little funnier
though Wally just bumping into everyone
on the Waverider like accidentally
calling
Amaya the basic [ __ ] communion I'm just
gonna ease you into the altered state
through some guided meditation thank you
for helping us so how do you know
Nathaniel I was kind of like his wingman
back in central city just helped him get
over a broken heart actually because
this basic [ __ ] just dumped him on his
birthday can you believe that
yeah cuz I was actually that basic [ __ ]
great vibe Wally I think we can take it
from you yeah yeah okay I'm gonna go
probably one of the funnier scenes in
the episode I'm that basic [ __ ] oh I'm
sorry
I'll just show myself out he also had a
liberal damian darhk-- tinder jokes I'm
more about swiping left to right do you
think it's too soon for me to stop
mourning your mother and look for
someone else and he starts swiping
through the dating app and all he gets
is Cupid from the eros Suicide Squad I
don't know if she's gonna be guest
starring in a future episode but if
there were ever any crazy women who
would be into people like damian darhk--
she would be the person but i do believe
she's alive out there somewhere i don't
think that she's one of the suicide
squad members that they killed off
number five all the no country jokes so
No Country for Old Men great movie Josh
Brolin Thanos himself is going to be
arriving in April this year and he
gonna be cable during Deadpool - so a
lot of no country things going on this
spring but his younger self has that
crazy Javier Bardem haircut which is
this hilarious every time he was on
screen I couldn't stop laughing at him
even though he's supposed to be super
hardcore like he gets the idea to learn
magic from himself when they're fighting
in that rooftop scene number four that
rooftop scene probably one of the best
fight scenes that they've done all
season just in the way that they cut the
tension with him trying to save Nora
because you care about her at this point
because they're actually giving her a
pretty good story arc this season
between her younger self and the adult
actress Courtney Ford is just a good
actress
she was actually great on dexter and
then the whole thing with her saving
herself by activating the totem which is
also kind of bad news for vixen so this
ended up being one of the best episodes
all season long but i think because it
was Wally's first big episode with the
team actually doing something they
really wanted to bring it but one of the
funnier things though is they're leaving
at the end of the episode is he says
that he's 257 years old like he was old
already in present day now obviously
they're traveling through time so he's a
little bit older he was still already
hundreds of years old at that time
because if you haven't watched those
arrow episodes in a while they explained
that he joined the League of Assassins
at the same time that this version of
rachel gould join which as he said would
have been more than 200 years ago number
three was the ball he saved time to show
us how fast you really are you're gonna
want to hold onto this and then the joke
that damian darhk-- makes I hate
speedsters is actually a callback to
that season 1 crossover with the Hawks
where he met Barry for the first time
he's just like what was that
what was that every time
number two was that surprised Grodd
attack and I love the way that they
pulled this off too because he jumped
back into frame so we as the audience
see him before the time bureau boss sees
him in his kills immediately deceased
agents would agree with the reasons now
you twice hunter in handcuffs this
instant
so broad didn't kill the entire time
bureau just a couple of its leaders to
fracture it then his rip hunter is going
back to the future it kind of slips out
a little teaser for the future and says
that Sarah must never know the truth
about Ava might have something to do
with Ava being tied to the villains of
the season are tied to malice she might
secretly be one of the acolytes it makes
more sense that they're making Ava such
a big part of the plot now like I was
wondering if she was just gonna be
Sarah's girlfriend but now it seems like
she's tied to this larger arc which i
think is a much better way to go it
makes a little more sense now in context
but number one of course is Rey creating
the time quake to alert the legends to
his location also serves as the straw
that broke the camel's back fracturing
time space enough so that it's like
paper-thin they make it sound like
Mallis is right about to crack out of
his prison like I thought it was gonna
have something to do with all the totems
coming together but it sounds like
that's more about trapping him not about
freeing him so obviously that means that
all the totem bears both evil and good
will have to come together to save the
day at the end of the season he also
brings with that hot chocolate which is
sort of a callback to the Constantine
episode when they were in the jitters
but it says GC jitters so a lot of you
are like wait a minute is that Gotham
City did he drop by Batman's town to
grab her some hot chocolate you can take
it that way I don't know what the rules
for mentioning Gotham on the TV show are
so this might be about as far as they
could take it so sure why not let's call
it a Batman Easter Egg so if it wasn't
clear there's still one missing mystery
totem it's actually gonna be the Jesse
quick Constantine crossover episode
that's right both Constantine and Jesse
quick are gonna get star in episode 15
it's called necromancing the stone so it
sounds like whatever this mystery totem
is it has something to do with raising
the dead or something to do with
manipulating life force so we'll find
out more about that in the next week or
two but obviously tomorrow is our big
flash family episode Jay Garrick and
Jesse quick helping Barry during enter
flash time so a whole bunch of flashed
up posting tomorrow I'm also working on
a new Avengers black order video there's
a lot of other requests I've gotten so
I'll try to get through them as fast as
possible so I'll just continue the
giveaway into my next flash trailer
video so that'll post sometime early
tomorrow
but click here for brand new flash and
click here for brand new Avengers and
Finn
any war thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight